I've been reviewing beauty products for
more than 10 years so not a lot of
things excite me but these things did
this year and I'm going to tell you why
and because I am a chemist and a massive
nerd I'm going into the science behind
why as well maybe some of these will
also become your favorites but if not
hopefully you will still learn something
new that you can use when you're finding
products for yourself if you tried any
of these let me know what you thought in
the comments let's get into it the LA
super serum is the best new product I've
tried in a really long time I did a
sponsored Instagram post on this but
this video isn't sponsored I'm purely
talking about it because it was such a
standup product so for all of my
sponsored posts and review posts my
process is I'll look at the claims and
ingredients and if that all makes sense
then I'll try it on my skin for usually
2 weeks maybe more depending on what the
product is this is really important
because even if you know everything
about Cosmetics you cannot tell just
from an ingredients list how well most
products work it's got limited
information the overall formula is
really important so you really need to
test it on actual Skin So for a serum
that has actives like this I will start
with my skin at its best I'll be using
my standard skincare routine for a few
weeks then I'll start using the new
serum as the only active product I'll
still be using things like cleansers and
moisturizers and sunscreens that I'm
really familiar with so I know what
they're going to do to my skin I can see
any difference then usually over the
next few days there'll be little skin
issues popping up my most common one is
closed chodon these are little flesh
color bumps that pop up usually around
my jaw area they when a porw gets
clogged it's sort of like a pimple but
not quite it could very well Veer into
pimple territory but it's just buildup
happening in a paw I'll usually let that
go on for a few days then I'll know
right this serum just doesn't work for
that so I'll Blitz them usually the
products for that for me are alpha
hydroxy acids and a peeling gel then
I'll just keep using the serum see if
that happens again go through this
process for a bunch of other skin issues
and then by the the end of the trial
period I'll have a really good idea of
what the product is and isn't good for
which products and ingredients it's good
at replacing sometimes my skin will just
hate a product or it might not do much
and then I'll go back to the brand and
tell them sorry I can't do a sponsor
post on this I can't endorse this
product and most of the time even with
products that I really like and
recommend there will be little issues
popping up and that's fine because most
serums aren't really designed to do
everything but with this serum this is
one of the very few products where I
went from my skin in Peak condition
dropped all my usual hard-hitting
actives and my skin just sort of stayed
the same so basically this just replaced
all the actives in my normal super
optimized maintenance routine without
making any sort of noticeable difference
I think I ended up using this
continuously for like 5 weeks because I
was just so surprised I was just waiting
for something to happen and nothing did
I was just using this then I had to add
a retinoid back in because this doesn't
have a retinoid and I want those
long-term effects that I talked about in
my retinoid video and that's threw my
skin out of whack and I had to add a
whole bunch of other stuff in to deal
with that it was sort of like one of
those old lady swallowed to fly and then
eventually she is a horse kind of
situations but if my skin wasn't such a
baby when it came to ration oids I feel
like I could have used this as the only
product in terms of what's in it it's
got a whole bunch of actives and I was
pretty skeptical at first because
usually when you have a product with
tons of actives there will be one active
that they'll really focus on getting to
work really well and then the other ones
would just be sort of sprinkled in for
marketing purposes but this does seem to
get several things to go on at the same
time the main Innovation here is laay
managed to get nice Cinema to stay
active at a low ph and that normally
doesn't work very well but they worked
out way it is patented laay and Proctor
and Gamble did a lot of that original
research on nide for skin they kind of
like the nide science people so this
makes the nce andite get into skin a lot
more easily and according to their
testing data this works a lot faster
than LA's other best ninite products and
since nyami does a little bit of
everything in skincare I think that's
why this works so well plus it has
lactic acid as its second active and
lactic acid is one of those things that
works really well for my clogged pores
on top of that there's also pmol
pentapeptide 4 which is one of the
better supported peptides there's one of
my favorite vitamin C derivatives
there's also hyaluronic acid and
panthenol so it is really gentle and
non- irritating and it's also hydrating
I didn't actually need to use a
moisturizer most of the time when I
tried it and that was in winter in
Australia the main downside of this is
that it does have a moderate level of
fragrance which is actually quite a nice
fragrance to me but I can imagine that
some people might be really bothered by
it the other big downside which is
possibly a bigger downside is that it
hasn't launched in Australia I don't
know when or if it'll launch maybe it'll
launch with slightly less fragrance
because Australian products do tend to
be lighter and fragrant so when I went
to the US and smelled your products I
finally understood why everyone hates
fragrance so much because it was just
like the average level was just really
obnoxious La also have that really
annoying Mass Market brand thing where
they have a whole bunch of products with
similar names there's a whole range
called super serums but as far as I know
this formula only comes in this like
pretty shiny round bottle this isn't
really a new innovation but it made a
really big difference to my life this
year working out how to find eyeliner
pencils that St on oily skin my eyelids
are super oily so eyeliners always just
smudge or start transferring after a few
hours and I didn't really know what
exactly I was looking for I'd look for
reviews where people say particular
eyeliners were smudge proof but then
they would smudge on my Lids so clearly
my eyelids are just a whole level above
so here's what you're looking for number
one you want a volatile solvent at the
top of the ingredient list volatile
means that ingredient evaporates really
easily and these are the most common
ones you'll see in makeup the solvent
itself self isn't the bit that makes it
longwear but it's a sign that there are
film forming polymers in the product
that will stick together after those
solvents have evaporated off so the
solvent basically leaves and then the
film forming polymers they can get
together and form a really nice
long-lasting film the second thing
you're looking for is snug packaging and
again this just shows that there are
volatile solvents in there there's
enough in there that they're looking for
gas type packaging so that stops these
volatile solvents from escaping and
evaporating and making your product dry
out and shrivel and turn into like a
lump if you remember the gel eyeliners
that came in pots they were super
popular maybe 5 10 years ago they're a
lot less popular now because the same
Tech has now been put into pencil form
it makes it a lot more practical as a
product because then you don't have a
separate brush that you need to carry
around and it doesn't dry out and you
have to wash the brush and a big part of
why they're now in these pencils is
because of these packaging Innovations
some brands have been using these for
years but they are way more common now
basically for a really good gas Tite
seal you need one hard component that
mashes into a softer component with
pressure that's the same principle
behind how screw top products work they
just kind of give you a way of mashing
like the hard top of the container into
the soft seal on the inside of the
bottle so for eyeliners what you're
looking for is a really thick lid that
feels like it really jams on you can
kind of hear them creaking on this is my
favorite gel eyeliner pencil it's from
Revlon and I hate Revlon because they
always make these really good eye
products and then just randomly
discontin them all the time and I'm
really annoyed but I keep going back
because they are so good this is a
pencil in a barrel that you need to
sharpen and that is generally easier to
make gas tip but these days there are
windup products that work really well
too this is the Maybelline Master liner
and this one is cool because the wind up
part is actually inside the lid so you
can see like the the crack where the two
components join is in there inside the
seal also see that this packaging just
overall has very few lines and gaps on
it and you can see there is this kind of
thick seal inside the lid the Mery first
gel eyeliner is also one of my favorites
this is a wind up product and the
whining part is on the outside but it's
got a surprisingly good seal it's also
got like the thick lid that jams on as
well you can feel that the wind up part
is quite stiff and so yeah there is a
good seal in there and this hasn't dried
out I've had it for quite a while now
but yeah super good product another
thing to look out for if there are oily
ingredients that are high up in the
ingredients list that is going to be
risk year and one of the common
ingredients you'll see there is
dimethicone it's not a complete deal
breaker there are products that work
really well with dimethicone high on the
ingredients list and dimethicone does
make the product apply smoother but it
does increase the chances that it'll
smudge if you have oily Lids basically
it acts like a solvent it acts like a
makeup remover along with your own
natural oils and that dissolves the film
and makes it smudge and speaking of
solvents dissolving next we have the
bioderma eye makeup remover so I have
raved about the bierma Mel water so many
times it is hands down my favorite no
rinse cleanser myel water has
surfactants in it these are the
cleansing ingredients that you'll find
in every cleansing product like shampoo
body wash even dishwashing detergent but
there are a huge range of surfactants
available it's like a really really big
diverse family and so the Innovation
with these myel Waters was to find
surfactants that clean well but they
aren't irritating if you leave them on
your skin now some myel Waters don't do
this well which is why a lot of people
who have tried maybe one or two say you
absolutely need to rinse myell Waters
but this one was actually designed for
and tested on sensitive skin so this is
really really gentle works really well
for most people I found this so useful
for evenings when I couldn't handle
washing my face at a sink and dealing
with all the water it's also been really
useful for washing my face when I'm
trying to avoid a particular area like a
few weeks ago I microbladed my brows and
I had to kind of like paint around my
brows so yeah this year I went through
another few bottles but the new new
product I wanted to talk about is the
bif phasic myel eye makeup remover I've
always really liked two-phase eye makeup
removers this is where you have like a
layer of oily stuff over a layer of
water I found that these just work
really well for removing eye makeup
they're really gentle they don't need a
lot of tugging and yeah it's just quick
and easy but one of my big annoyances
with these is that the two layers
usually separate way too quickly so you
shake it and then you have to race to
get it onto your cleansing pad before it
starts separating if you get too much
oil on it then it ends up being really
greasy and leaving like a greasy layer
on your skin if you get too much of the
water layer then it doesn't take off eye
makeup as well and most of the time you
are getting a lot more oil than the
water so then halfway down through the
bottle you've used up all of the oil and
you just have tons of water left and
it's pretty annoying so one exciting
thing about this is that it actually
shakes
up I timed this once and it took about
10 minutes for it to completely separate
so that's why I've got a second bottle
here so that I can show you the two
phases as well as the Shakeen up one I
thought it was just some sort of
accident that this happened but it turns
out it is actually intentional and Boga
have a patient for this it's called
ecobiology cosmetic composition with
delayed phase separation so the way this
works is they use just the right amount
of polyglycerol ten laurate which is a
surfactant and that keeps the two layers
mixed together or emulsified for longer
than you need to get the product out
onto your cotton Pad but it still
separates into two layers by the next
time you use it it isn't the biggest
issue it's more like mildly infuriating
and I guess it is a bit of a waste if
you have a whole bunch of water left and
no oil in a product but I just thought
it was really neat that someone at
bioderma was also mildly infuriated
enough to actually solve this issue the
next product is the naked Sunday's spf50
lip oils this one is less of like a
specific product Innovation as far as I
can tell anyway maybe there is something
in here that I'm missing but the reason
it is innovative I guess is because this
product sort of just ticks off a whole
bunch of things I needed in an SPF lip
product I feel like the main thing that
made a difference for me is actually
just the fact it's in a doe foot
applicator I know I have kind of mixed
feelings on this because it is kind of
gross like you are putting it on your
lips and then like dunking it back in
and it goes back and forth a whole bunch
but it is preserved so it should be fine
it's just like mentally a bit gross I
guess but anyway all of that is not an
issue because it just makes it so much
easier to reapply it's so much messy
it's really easy to just get it on your
lips you don't end up with sticky
fingers and that sticky finger issue is
such a big issue when I'm at the beach I
just don't want sand all over my stuff I
want to be able to get the lip gloss
onto my lips without touching it with my
fingers without risking sand it also
just acts like a regular lip gloss it
smells really good they've got four
different flavors I think I've tried
watermelon Cherry um coconut those are
all really nice they're salted caramel
which I'm a bit more iffy on it sort of
has this like coffee is caramel Aroma
I'm sure a lot of people like it to me
it's just weird because it just makes me
feel like I have coffee breath without
the advantage of having coffee it also
has no Menthol which is nice I'm not
like a menthol hater I just don't like
the feeling of it for myself on my lips
it also looks really nice on your lips
it's really nice and shiny and it is
really hydrating I have big lips and all
my life they've been really prone to
getting dehydrated and cracked so I am
really picky with lip balms only a few
them will work for me so looking for an
SPF lip balm it's just been a mission I
guess the main downside is that it does
have a bit of a sunscreen taste but that
is kind of unavoidable with an SPF lip
product I do find that having a do foot
makes it a lot easier to aim it away
from like your lips so I've had less of
an issue with these on the topic of lips
I also wanted to shout out some normal
lip balms non SPF that I've just found
really good this year the dermal therapy
lip balm is really inexpensive it's
about $6 at Chemist Warehouse but it is
kind of hard to get overseas chem
Warehouse do ship overseas though if you
want to give this a go I've also been
really enjoying the propolis lip
sleeping mask from cosrx this is just a
really nice product it just works really
well for softening my lips overnight
there's also the stess lip glaze which
has just been my main lip gloss that
I've been using when I'm not using the
Naked Sundays ones on to some shampoos I
have a super irritation prone scalp I've
had issues all my life and most shampoos
will make my head itchy within 24 hours
and that's one of the main reasons why I
wash my hair every day there are even
some shampoos that make my head itchy
after only 12 hours it is so annoying so
it's really rare that I find shampoos
that keep my scalp calm for more than
maybe a day I will talk about irritator
scalp more in like a later video the
science behind why it happens and what
you can do about it but in the meantime
I just wanted to shout out some shampoos
that worked really well for my scalp if
you have any shampoos that work really
well for your irritated scalp please let
let me know in the comments so I can add
them to my testing list it's always been
really annoying to talk about shampoos
because the way they work is really
complicated it's the ingredients working
together I talked about it a bit in my
shampoo science video it is more about
the overall formula and so the ratio of
different ingredients makes a huge
difference and you can't just tell that
from an ingredients list I've tried
maybe 50 new shampoos as part of this
quest to work out the goly Grail
irritated scalp shampoos the only real
patterns I found are these maybe these
will help you firstly avoiding Mi and
MCI and these are really common
preservatives I'll put their full names
here a lot of people are allergic to
them they are some of the most common
allergens in beauty products and it's
annoying because they are in a lot of
shampoos the other big thing that helped
me is using shampoos with ingredients
that control yeast you might have heard
of malesia yeast this is the thing that
overgrows and causes dandruff but this
yeast can also cause irritation even
without getting full-on dandruff flakes
one relatively new ingredient that I've
been appreciating is pyone alamine this
has come in because it's replacing zinc
pythium which was the old super popular
anti-dandruff ingredient that got
Limited in the EU this isn't quite as
powerful but it is really nice and
formless because it's just really Bland
like you can't tell that it is an anti-
dander shampoo some of my favorite
shampoos for this are listed here but
I've also tried shampoos with it that
just do the same irritation thing so
it's clearly not like a complete blanket
rule I've also been using the deros
seleno Sufi shampoos about once a week
but I'm quite sensitive to the smell of
sulfur because I was working in a lab
with lots of sulfa stuff and this just
brings back terrible
memories so I don't love using it but
this is one of the least sulfus smelling
selenium Sufi shampoos I've used and the
effect does last longer so I don't
exactly have to use it every single wash
on top of that I have also found some
shampoos that don't have specific
actives but they've been really nice for
my scalp so so I think it is more of
that formulation thing I'll go into more
detail about all the shampoos I've tried
in my later video whenever that gets
done but this is just a really short
list of some shampoos that let me go
more than 24 hours without washing maybe
it will benefit some of you in the
meantime everything is linked in the
description if you want more reviews you
can check out my reviews playlist if you
want more nerdy Beauty signs I did a
deep dive into Ral recently honestly my
entire channel is nerdy Beauty signs so
check that out and if you haven't like
And subscribe